hoy en cultura un solo nombre el del
bandoneonista y compositor argentino
astor pantaleón piazzolla por el
centenario de su nacimiento marzo es un
mes y 2021 su año pero cualquier razón
bastaría para el eterno experimentador
del tango que con la libertad que le
otorgó el jazz trascendió el género y
fue el primero en sostener con sus
tripas un bandoneón que además tenía su
propio sonido ya sola fue un genio
trabajador y un virtuoso provocador pero
estos innovadores armonías y ritmos lo
llevaron a más hacer de los más
prolíficos artistas del siglo 20 y a
cambiar por siempre la música mundial
en un mundo confitado como descendientes
de italianos con una dulcería así
describía a xunta manet y la mar del
plata- que en 1921 vio nacer a su hijo
pantaleón por el abuelo paterno pero
astor por un amigo músico que triunfó en
eeuu hasta allí emigraron y en gran
parte ese duro nueva york de gangs
definió napia sola de niño a adolescente
marcaría su gusto por las bandas su
lucha por un sonido pero sobre todo fue
así que su padre vicente lo instó a
clases de música y a un bandoneón que
hubiera preferido patines pero los 17
tras enamorarse del tango oyendo al
sexteto de elvino vardaro consiguió ser
el gato inquieto de la orquesta de
aníbal troilo su dios en la meca
bonaerense y estudiar junto a alberto
ginastera
un paso por grupos hizo arreglos para
otros compositores y música para cine si
bien sin hacer ahí nadie abulense en
parís fueron claves para afirmar el
tango como faro vocacional sin perder a
bach o el jazz de harlem
es así como a mitad de los cincuenta
deja de renegar del género e inicia su
revolución nuevo tango con el objeto
buenos aires hasta su muerte en 1992
debido a un ataque cerebral
su pasión adquiría varias bandas y
fracasos pero apenas se levantaba iba al
piano a trabajar otro ritmo melodía y
estética y con grandes como que ritmo
ligan si le costó la leyenda
detener a los tradicionalistas en contra
me toque el mismo anti política anti
rock argentino y reñido con jorge luís
borges un poco provocaba si bien al
final siempre prevalecía su genio y sus
1500 obras escritas algunas entre
tiburones por eso siempre deseo más
tiempo para componer y superar el adiós
nonino y para lograr esa ilusión de que
su libertad
oblivion se escucharan hoy y también en
el año 3000
[Música]
para abordar su figura hoy tenemos con
nosotros a su biógrafa maría susana h
gracias maría susana sonará muy
romántica esta primera pregunta pero el
tango surgió en los puertos entre
migración y mezcla también musical y un
poco pasó la tenía eso bajo la piel es
por eso que supo romper esquemas
experimentar el género
que asola rompió con el género porque
también estuvo expuesto a diferentes
culturas en los cuatro años se fue con
sus padres en barco a la ciudad de nueva
york y allí escuchó plasmar en las aguas
judías el rap hasta en el jazz y el
blues su padre cuando regresaba del
trabajo escuchaba a los tangos de julio
de caro y de carlos gardel y como los
padres se les decían los ojos escuchando
esta música que a solá odiaba esa música
porque porque es los padres se ponían
tristes con esa música él le encantaba
tocar la armónica y bueno volvieron otra
vez a mar de plata a raíz del crack del
21 de 30 por nueve meses regresaron otra
vez a new york' y cuando regresaron
definitivamente a la ciudad más de plata
pienso la tenía 16 años
se enamoró del tango algo que el padre
no lo podía crear porque el padre le
regaló un instrumento un bandoneón
cuando él cumplió 8 años no fue
solamente un instrumento musical sino
que fue un mandato cultural y musical
cultural al decirle sentirte argentino
sea argentino no te sientas un
inmigrante desarraigado dicho que asola
durante su carrera él sabía 3000 tangos
de memoria él podía componer en
cualquier lugar del mundo no necesitaba
estar en la sede buenos aires- una
mezcla muy inteligente entre el tango el
jazz la música clásica contemporánea sus
ídolos
johann sebastian bach béla bartók higos
también es que maurice ravel y alguno
que otro compositor de tango de aquellos
que seguían la corriente evolucionista y
no la tradicionalista él llegó a decir q
tuvo tres maestros tres grandes maestros
la siega buenos aires o sea el tango
alberto ginastera y nadia boulanger y yo
por las razones ya expuestas agregue un
cuarto maestro su padre a quien los
hijos de astor de la mirada no ni no
esto creía en una música con swing que
tuviera improvisación que diera peso a
la banda y que incluyera esta guitarra
eléctrica cuánto es el jazz que cita
este fue responsable de esa inquietud
tan innovadora y como dio forma a su
sonido
existen sólidos días o horas y le fue a
las formas por ejemplo hay obras como
tres minutos de la realidad que tiene
mucho de stravinsky debo decir que
también tiene mucho de béla bartók
porque él escribió esa obra después de
haber escuchado una hora de béla bartók
y él escribió muy rápido en una noche
como escribía siempre o sea hay de mi
licencia derivar diez obras de ravel de
los músicos que mencioné siempre con una
regular y estudio el contrapunto con el
salto de línea este estudio orquestación
porque pienso la escribía para cada uno
de sus solistas escribía para los
cimientos de cada uno de ellos para el
lucimiento de cada uno de los conjuntos
que formó y para los cimientos de su
propia música estuvo porque esta típica
quinteto o octetos dos quintetos dos
actos un sexteto uno neto y también
alguna formación con doce músicos la
obra que más tocó el que más quiso fue a
ellos nonino que es un homenaje a su
padre
acaba de fallecer también está el tango
y después están las improvisaciones que
vienen del jazz pero que no tienen que
ser improvisaciones con temas del jazz
deben inventar improvisaciones con
frases de tango eso fue una absoluta
novedad y como bien le dijiste la
guitarra eléctrica
jamás se había utilizado en un grupo de
tango horacio malvicino el guitarrista
integró el objeto electrónico que formó
pie sola ya él lo llamaban tanto y lo
mismo que hacía sola con amenazas de
muerte porque estaban asesinando el
tango
justo de niño se ganó el apodo de left y
no un zurdo que era peleón pero su mayor
riña la tuvo con los ortodoxos del tango
realmente que les molestaba que él solo
transformara el género o que lo tildara
de monótono que no lo quisiera bailable
en realidad cuando pienso la escucha
además en la ciudad de parís y escucha a
estos músicos de jazz que tocaban con
alegría dijo yo quiero esto para mi
tango para mi música a la cual llamó
música de la ciudad buenos aires para no
tener más esta lucha vida solista
antigua solista ahí también decidió
componer para cada uno de los artistas
como dije antes y tomó una decisión de
tocar el bandoneón de pie eso fue su
grito de libertad y la independencia la
tradición tanguera porque siempre se
había tocado al mandado sentado
él decía que necesitaba ver a sus
músicos desde lo alto para poder
dirigirlos y tampoco quería parecerse
una vieja tejiendo sentada
los místicos tangueros tradicionalistas
no lo comprendieron porque era una
música mucho más difícil muy intrincada
de asola jamás dejó de evolucionar ya
fuera en la forma de escribir la música
pues los diversos conjuntos musicales
que lleva creando de su tango era para
ser escuchado y apuntaba no no fue
voluntario pero bueno ya que lo tocaba
en diferentes locales en unos bailables
ahí asistí a un público que cuál le
gustaba el jazz la bossa nova y la
música internacional por lo cual no era
un mundo que compartía con la gente que
iba a bailar el tango que además debo
decir que era de otro poder adquisitivo
la gente que llega y comprar una entrada
para escuchar aquella sola era un poco
un poquito más caro que la entrada para
bailar el tango
pero aquí encontramos dos elementos a
ese actor que aguanta que de pie el
bandoneón más ese actor que después de
los shows se peleaba no no es así a
pesar de que con lo que hacía la
componía era difícil era esa su
personalidad es decir quién era piasol
además de este músico que cazaba
tiburones
fue un ser muy creativo muy valiente
corajudo con mucha energía con una gran
fuerza que nunca se dejó vencer a pesar
de que los mortifica vamos mucho cada
vez que regresaba a la argentina desde
europa con novedades queriendo las
llevadas país mostrarlas y no eran bien
recibidas eso le dolió mucho era una
persona muy sensible que no lo
demostraba humanamente pero demostraba a
través de su música como lo demuestra a
través de su música porque su música
refleja todo el repertorio de las
emociones humanas esto nos lleva a 1983
que le pidió a su nieto pipe a danielle
que no olvidará la noche en que triunfó
con la sinfónica en el teatro colón de
buenos aires
pese a todo necesito la bendición de su
tierra maría susana
el necesitaba esa bendición de su tierra
y él sintió cuando toco en el teatro
colon
llegué y con respecto de la lucha ya su
carácter guerrero de no rendirse nunca
jamás en aprender a luchar las calles de
nueva york porque formaba parte de una
pandilla de niños judíos irlandeses
italianos y se peleaban mucho era un
chico una fanta
bueno eso también lo fue de grande
porque además de ejercer su profesión de
músico con excelencia era muy chistoso
hacía chistes negros pero que no le
hicieron a él esos chistes y así como no
podría pescar mojarritas si no debía
pescar tiburones porque no ser muy
intenso quedar 150 o 200 conciertos por
años
necesitaba pescar al menos tres veces a
la semana en la ciudad por está del
estado no estoy yo en este momento en
uruguay
así investigue hasta el genio astor
desde el 95 y no sé qué te sorprende más
si su exigencia de músico liberal o que
hoy se aceite antes que asola que tango
con decenas artistas que lo honran
todos me sorprenden porque todo en su
vida como hombre y como músico es muy
sorprendente personalmente me sorprende
porque cuando yo inicié este
investigación en 1995 escuchaba a mi me
gusta el tango no me gusta está sola y
hoy escucho en el 2021
me gusta pie sola no me gusta el tango y
me ha impresionado su sacrificio su
esfuerzo sacrificó su vida familia la
situación económica propia y sacrifico
su salud en pos de su música fue el
ingenio musical que asola al ciento por
ciento de eso no se arrepintió jamás y
el mundo se lo reconoce gracias mare
susana por su presencia y aunque
nosotros nos despedimos con el clásico
adiós nonino les invitamos a escribirnos
con las canciones que más allá sentido
de piaf hola
muchas gracias y cuídense
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]